One of the biggest barriers to
interpersonal communication is our
concern that people aren't interested in
what we have to say. If we're just a
little bit more social, we can
dramatically change the impact of our
communication. My name is Matt Abrahams
and I teach strategic communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
Welcome to Think Fast, Talk Smart, the
podcast.
Today I look forward to learning from
Nick Epley. Nick is a professor of
behavioral science at the University of
Chicago Booth School of Business, where
he also directs the Roman Family Center
for Decision Research. Nick's research
focuses on how people make inferences
about the minds of others and why we
routinely misunderstand each other.
His first book is called Mindwise: How
We Understand What Others Think,
Believe, Feel, and Want. And his latest
book is A Little More Social: How Small
Choices Create Unexpected Happiness,
Health, and Connection. Well, welcome,
Nick. I am so excited to chat with you.
You have the distinction of being the
person most cited by other guests, from
Charles Duhigg to Katy Milkman to Laurie
Santos, and I am so glad to finally get
a chance to talk to you. Thanks for
being here.
>> Yeah, thank you. That is very flattering
and you should be flattered to know that
one of your recent guests, Sonja
Lyubomirsky, also said, who she does a
lot of podcasts, said this was one of
the favorite that she'd done in a long,
long while.
>> very kind of Sonja. We've known each
other a long time and we had a great
conversation. So, shall we get started?
>> Yes, absolutely.
>> Okay.
So, in your book Mindwise, you discuss
how we are fundamentally overconfident
in our ability to read other people's
minds.
We often rely on what you call outside
perspective, things like
the way people use their bodies, facial
expressions, to really figure out what
someone is thinking. Uh why is this the
wrong approach? Why are we ineffective?
And how can we get better using what you
call the inside perspective?
>> So, the thing that really makes us stand
out on the planet as a species, at least
from a psychologist's perspective, is
our ability to think about other people.
Much of our neural capacity here, this
fat part of our brain up above our eyes,
is dedicated to social cognition,
thinking about other thinking people.
The problem is that other people's minds
are the most complicated things you will
ever think about. And so, we're
imperfect. We're imperfect, though, in
predictable ways.
Um
we there are a handful of of reliable
biases that that we commit. One question
we can then ask is how do we overcome
these mistakes that we make? One common
approach is to just try to pay attention
to other people's body language. The
problem we find with that, or that many
psychologists find with that, is that
bodies can often mislead. It's easy to
lie to people or or deceive other people
in ways that are hard to detect. We're
often barely above chance, for instance,
in being able to detect whether somebody
is uh is telling us the truth or lying
to us. So, body language doesn't work
actually that well, or reading body
language. Sometimes we can try to put
ourselves in other people's shoes. We
find in our research that doesn't
actually increase accuracy a whole
bunch. You're still playing with things
that are in your own head. You're not
gaining new insight. Perspective taking
isn't quite the magical elixir for
understanding that we might imagine. The
only way that we have found for people
to understand the minds of other people
better is to wait for it,
ask them what they are thinking. Now, I
remember when we started running these
experiments, that is actually have to
get on your inside. I have to ask you
what you're thinking to be a good good
at understanding another person. You
have to become a good journalist, it
turns out, a good interrogator. Um when
we first started running these
experiments in my lab, we referred to
these as the stupid studies. That
obviously asking somebody what they
think is going to give you more insight
into what's on their mind, but what was
interesting to us was that people didn't
seem to know that they were actually
using a good strategy when they were
using it. So, we had people engaging in
perspective taking, thought they were
doing just as well, just as accurate
understanding the mind of another person
as people who were directly asking
another person what they thought about
something. And that was what was
interesting to us. Using this most
effective strategy didn't, from people's
own perspectives, um
didn't seem to be something that they
are were aware was actually helping them
out as much as it was.
>> And one of
dive deeper into this notion of uh
you said perspective taking doesn't
really work, and I know you've done a
lot of work on what you call perspective
getting.
>> Yes. Clearly, asking is one way to get
another person's perspective. Can can
you define what you mean by perspective
getting, and what are some tools that we
can use, especially in high-stakes
situations where reading the room and
understanding somebody else's likely
response could be really helpful to us?
>> All we mean by perspective getting is
just an analog to the psychological
process of perspective taking. And we
didn't mean anything magical by it when
we came up with the term. In fact, it's
hardly the kind of thing that even needs
a term. Psychologists for decades have
been studying what happens when we do
this little bit of mental gymnastics to
move from my perspective to yours, to
try to see things from your point of
view, try to understand things from your
perspective, recognizing that you might
see the world differently than I do.
To be clear, doing that does a lot of
things psychologically for us. It makes
me feel more similar to you. It makes me
feel more empathy towards you. It makes
me feel like I understand you better
when I do this. The problem is when I
actually ask people to predict what
you're thinking and you write down what
you're actually thinking, people
perspective taking doesn't actually make
people, we found in a series of 25
experiments, doesn't actually make
people more accurate. Um if anything it
made people a little bit worse, right?
So by perspective getting, all we mean
is simply asking other people questions
directly about what might what they
might think about something in a
negotiation. You could ask somebody
directly, "Look, I really want to
understand what you want in the
situation, what your position is." You
might be worried that they might not
tell you, but you can ask. You might
want to know, for instance, what your
spouse wants for Christmas or for
birthday, right? Instead of guessing, it
turns out the best way to know is to ask
them. And they tend to be just as happy
getting the gift that they wanted when
you asked them as when you guessed and
got the got the wrong one. They're not
so happy about that. So, what can you do
in a high-stakes situation? I think the
big thing, one thing we're finding out
in in recent research, is that people
are often reluctant to ask direct
questions.
>> Right.
>> They feel like it's being too nosey.
It's being impolite. It's being
intrusive. Uh and so they're reluctant
to ask the questions they would need to
actually understand another person. In
our research, um we find that people
think it's going to be awkward to ask
somebody a direct question about what
they believe about some topic,
particularly if it's a personally
relevant or meaningful topic. Um but
people who are asked those questions,
even sensitive ones. So, this is work by
Einav Hart and Maurice Schweitzer, for
instance. They find that people think
it's going to be much more awkward to
ask somebody direct questions than the
person actually finds it to be.
When you ask somebody a direct question,
they actually uh they don't they
typically don't mind as much as you
would guess. So, I think that's the big
thing in a high-stakes
situation, just ask the question you
want to know the answer to.
>> Uh
I I I'm hearing a theme that asking is
very important. So So, my question for
you is
what makes for a good question? You
know, on the show we people have said
open questions better than closed
questions. Do you have uh
recommendations for what what are
questions that can give you insight
perhaps over other questions?
>> So, one of the things that I'm most
interested about in my in my work is
trying to understand why we don't do the
social things that aren't necessarily
good for us. Why we don't communicate in
the ways that would otherwise be good
for us, creating connections with other
people, allowing us to understand them
better, and so on. What are the barriers
that keep us from doing it? And a big
one A big one is just misunderstanding
how other people will respond. So, for
me, the the the best kinds of questions
to ask somebody are the meaningful ones.
Meaningful questions, deep questions
that ask about somebody's thoughts or
their beliefs or their attitudes or
their feelings. In conversation, these
are the kinds of things we often want to
be talking about with somebody, and yet
these are also the things that we're
often reluctant to ask people about, and
so we spend a lot of time in
conversation, say, or even when
communicating with other people, talking
about kind of shallow, superficial
things that don't really enable
understanding, don't really enable uh as
much understanding as it could, and
don't allow us to connect with other
people as meaningfully as we otherwise
as we otherwise could. So, for me, the
the questions that are of most interest
to ask are the deep ones and the ones
that we're often overly reluctant to ask
people about.
>> Absolutely. And And you can think about
some of those in advance, right? You You
can You can stockpile some questions.
And And, you know, we've we've talked
with Alison Wood Brooks and others about
how how we can leverage questions to
build more connection, trust, and
intimacy with people. Do you have advice
or guidance on how to move from those
shallow conversations
into more meaningful ones? I might feel
very uncomfortable starting by asking
you a very deep question right off the
bat. It might be easier How do we
migrate from the the more shallow to the
to the deeper questions?
>> Much faster than you think you can.
>> Okay.
>> So, you might not ask that your first
question, but I usually can get to
something meaningful by question number
two,
if I'm trying.
And I think that's a thing that people
really must misunderstand in
conversation. Usually, um that
transition for me
moves from talking about something or
asking about something early on that's
kind of on the outside of a person.
What do you do for a living? Where do
you live? To something that's very
quickly on the inside of a person. And
that often involves a shift from asking
about what might be happening to asking
about why or some deeper deeper meaning.
So, once I find out what you do for a
living, I can ask you why why do you do
that and not something else?
>> Right.
>> Or I can ask you something, you know, I
ask you what you do for a living, and I
can ask as a follow-up question, is that
always what you wanted to do?
>> Right.
>> your dream job? Do you have your dream
job right now, right? And if they say
yes, then you can ask, well, why is that
your dream job?
And if they say no, you can ask, well,
what is your dream job?
And already there, on like the third
question, I've gotten to somebody's
dreams.
>> Yeah.
>> It just doesn't take that long.
>> I like that distinction of going from
what to why. And I it's really important
to to put up an exclamation point at the
end of what you said is that while we
feel it might be awkward, in actuality,
it's not that awkward.
>> What we found was creating the barrier,
why people didn't want to talk, was that
people didn't think that others were
interested in talking to them.
>> Oh, interesting.
>> And that's also what keeps people from
having the deep meaningful kind of
conversations we'd like to be having
with each other. Too, we find that
people think that others aren't going to
care
about the stuff that they have to share,
the meaningful things that they would
have to share in conversation, the sense
that other people don't want to be
bothered with this or wouldn't be
interested in having this conversation,
and
turns out we're we're off about that.
>> Wow, so it's it our our fear that the
other one person just doesn't care or
want to be burdened with our stuff is
what gets in the way.
>> It's not that we misunderstand
ourselves. We know, I mean, in our in
our experiments people recognize that if
you had a conversation with somebody, if
you
shared something meaningful about
yourself, people would enjoy their
experience more if they were in a
conversation than if they were being
ignored by other people, but what keeps
them from doing it is a social cognition
error.
>> Right.
>> A mind reading mistake is that I think
you don't want to talk to me,
and of course, if I don't think you want
to talk to me, I won't try, and I'll
never find out that I'm wrong about
that.
>> Right. And your research shows that when
you do actually initiate the
conversation, there there wonderful
benefits from it.
Is
people vary. As a lot of the work I have
done is with people who are highly
anxious in communicating,
you know, introverts, extroverts. Oh,
what
how can somebody who might be nervous, a
a non-native speaker for example, or
somebody who who's just extremely shy or
introverted, how do you you encourage
them to take advantage of this
wonderful benefit of talking to people?
>> So, I I empathize with this very much
because I was one time there.
That is, I I now can stand up in front
of a thousand people without any trouble
and give a speech, and I teach, I mean,
we're academics, we do this for a
living. When I was in graduate school, I
was horrified by the thought of standing
up and presenting in public. I was
horrified about the thought of taking
questions. So, I very much can empathize
with the challenges that that come from
opening up and and reaching out. The
long-run answer is that you overcome
mistaken fears through practice.
That's it. Is you learn that these are
mistaken by exposing yourself to them
and learning the truth of the matter. In
fact, um cognitive behavioral
therapists, psychologists who treat
clinical levels of anxiety, the way they
do this is through what's known as
exposure therapy.
>> Right.
>> Where they put you in the very situation
that you were anxious about. Now,
exposure therapy doesn't work for every
everything, but if your concern is about
talking to people, as social stuff,
those anxieties tend to be misplaced.
So, putting yourself in those situations
um is is the is the step that you need
to calibrate your beliefs. Now, how do
you do that? What I recommend to people
is doing a choice audit um of your day.
Just Just think over the course of your
day, like your day tomorrow. You know,
you might think about a moment where you
could engage with somebody. It'd be
easy. Wouldn't be hard, right? Where you
could reach out and engage with
somebody. It wouldn't take a lot of
time. Wouldn't take a lot of effort.
Wouldn't take a lot of energy. And start
there.
>> Mhm.
>> Sometimes these can be really simple
things. Like, when I enter the
University of Chicago Business School
where I work, the Harper Center here uh
in Hyde Park on the University of
Chicago campus, I've got about a 200-yd
walk up to my office where I'm standing
right now.
And I have taken on as a habit making
that a hello walk. So, I and I I've done
this very deliberate. Like, I had this
realization one morning that I kind of
walk into the office, head down, on my
way, not wanting to bother anybody. And
uh and I decided to do something
different, right? There was a moment
where I was choosing to ignore people.
And I could do something different. So,
now when I come in, I've my head up. I'm
smiling. Now, that seems small. It is
small.
A lot of these things are small. Saying
hello to somebody on the train one
morning. You're there, you're not doing
anything anyway. It's easy.
Relatively speaking. It's not
particularly hard. It's not risky.
Um, and that's the place to start. What
we're talking about here is uh the way
you change behavior over the long run is
you don't do it all at once. You're not
going to overcome anxiety all at once.
It's you you don't move a mountain by
pushing
>> the whole thing at one time.
>> Right.
>> You move a mountain, you know, shovel by
shovel.
>> Right.
>> Bit by bit. And so my advice to folks
who are nervous about this is you don't
have to believe me.
You don't have to believe our data.
You can go out and test this yourself
and my suggestion is to start small.
Pick a little thing you can do that's
pretty easy. Give somebody a compliment.
Right? Say hello to somebody in line. Do
it multiple times so you get some data
and that's where you start.
>> So many things there that you said are
are so valuable and insightful. One, I
would never have believed that you were
shy and nervous about speaking. You you
are you come off as quite the extrovert
and and very comfortable. This idea of
doing a
choice audit to to think about where
those opportunities are for these little
experiments that you're talking about
and I am certainly going to try and I
encourage everybody listening to try a
hello walk and see what happens as we
go. Your new book is called A Little
More Social. It's not Be Social. It's
not jump into the deep end of social.
Talk to me about the thesis of A Little
More Social. Tell me a little bit more
about why you use a little bit more and
what it's about.
>> The book is trying to reconcile what
seems like a fundamental paradox that
sits right at the core of human life to
me, which is that we're highly social
animals. We're made happier and
healthier by reaching out and connecting
with other people and yet that choice to
reach out and engage with somebody to
approach them or to hold back and avoid
them, right? That dynamic shows up. That
choice shows up in so many different
parts of our lives, right? So, do I talk
with a stranger? Do I type to them or
pick up the phone and call them, right?
Once I'm talking, do I go deep or do I
stay in the shallow end of the pool? I
got a kind thought, do I share it? I
feel grateful to somebody, do I express
it, right? I need help, do I ask for it,
right? I've got this thing about myself
that I'd like to share with my partner,
but I'm a little nervous about being
honest, so I keep my true self to
myself. Over and over again, there are
these opportunities that we have to
reach out and engage with others in
positive, meaningful ways that make our
lives better,
that we're often nervous about doing.
And what we find just over and over and
over and over and over again is that
avoidance voice, that that voice we have
on our shoulder that's telling us,
"They're not going to like that. This is
going to be bad." is a little too
strong.
And people consistently underestimate
how positively these interactions are
going to go. And as a result, I think
are overly reluctant to reach out and
engage with other people. Now, we're not
idiots. We're not Nobody is confused
that reaching out and expressing
gratitude to your old high school band
director, which I did not long ago.
Craig Anis is his name. Best teacher One
of the best teachers I've ever seen in
my in my life. Nobody's confused that
doing that is going to be negative,
right? We can distinguish between a pat
on the back and a punch in the face.
This we're not confused about this,
right?
>> Right.
>> But, what we do find is that even when
we think it's going to be a little good,
we we still underestimate how positively
these things are likely to be. We're a
little bit off. So, our data don't
suggest you should go out to talk to
everybody all the time. I mean, you got
things to do, right?
You got things to do. They don't suggest
you should dive into the deep end of the
conversation pool with everybody all the
time, or spend your life writing
gratitude letters.
That's not what I suggest. It suggests
that your estimate, your belief
about how this social interaction, this
attempt to reach out and engage with
somebody is going to go, is off a bit,
right? And all of life is a gamble. All
of life's a gamble on the outcomes are
of our decisions and our choices. And
our data suggests that we're a little
off about that. And as a result, there
probably lots of lots of social
interactions that you could have, but
you're mistakenly choosing not to have.
And finding those decision points where,
you know, that avoids voice is just a
little too strong in your life, that's
the margin you have for improving it,
for making your life better, right? And
again, the title of the book comes from
what I think is the real implication of
our work, not that you should be, you
know, a
a non-stop extrovert talking to other
people all the time, but that there are
choices you're making to avoid people
that are often mistaken. And that you
could be a little bit more social, and
it would make your life probably
considerably better.
>> I I am absolutely convinced, and as
somebody who's read the book, uh you do
a very articulate you do a great job of
helping articulate that point of view.
We'll be right back to finish our
conversation. But first, a quick word
from one of our sponsors. Their support
allows us to bring you this show free of
charge.
One of my favorite things about this
show is hearing from listeners all over
the world. Communication connects us.
And the more people you can communicate
with, the bigger your world becomes.
That's one reason I've been thinking
more and more about language learning.
What I appreciate about Babbel is that
it focuses on helping you have real
conversations with real people, not just
memorized vocabulary. Their lessons are
designed by more than 200 language
experts and built around practical
communication skills you can actually
use in everyday life. And because the
lessons are short and approachable, it's
easy to fit them in a busy schedule.
Just 10 minutes a day can help you make
meaningful progress. I think this is
especially relevant for our audience
because so many of you are collaborating
internationally, working across
cultures, or simply trying to connect
more deeply with people around the
world. If you've ever thought about
learning a new language, this is the
perfect opportunity to start. Right now,
Babel is offering up to 60% off your
subscription at babel.com/tfts.
That's babbel.com/tfts
for up to 60% off.
Rules and restrictions may apply. If you
enjoyed my recent conversation with Jean
and Sherry from the Tiger Sisters, I
think you'll really love their show.
Jean and Sherry are known as the
Internet's Wall Street and Silicon
Valley big sisters. And together,
they've built Tiger Sisters into a
top-ranked business podcast reaching
number one in business and top three
overall on Spotify in the US. They take
big and sometimes complicated ideas
around money, power, and love and turn
them into clear, practical tools you can
apply right away. Two fun facts, I
coached Sherry for her TEDx Talk and I
had the chance to join them on their
show and I have to say it was a really
thoughtful and engaging conversation.
They ask great questions and bring up
perspective you don't always hear. New
episodes drop every Monday on their
YouTube channel and across all audio
platforms at Tiger Sisters podcast.
>> You know, Nick, I knew this was going to
be wonderful because everybody your
resume came to me as oh my goodness,
it's going to be a great conversation.
It is it it I don't want to bring it to
an end, but we will.
Before we end, as you know,
I ask three questions, two questions I
ask everybody, one I come up with just
for you. Are you ready for these?
>> I'm ready. I'm ready for the speed
round.
>> All right. You teach an MBA course
called designing a good life.
>> Yep.
>> What is one communication-based design
flaw you see most high-achieving people
make and how can we change it to to be
better?
>> I think a big design flaw is people
focus too much on their competency and
too little on their warmth.
What other people care about when they
interact with us is is this person
trustworthy?
>> Mhm.
>> Is this person honest? Are they kind?
Are they a friend or are they somebody I
should avoid? We spend a lot of time
thinking about what exactly should I say
to communicate
to this person. That's a good second
thing to pay attention to because that's
what they're paying attention to second.
But the first thing they're paying
attention to is is this person warm? Are
they a friend? And I think that's a
mistake. We overestimate the importance
of competency, exactly what we're
communicating when we're communicating,
when really what matters a lot first and
foremost is
does this person uh is this person warm?
Is this person trustworthy? That's
That's the thing to start with.
>> Thank you for echoing that. In the
strategic communication class I teach,
that is the very first topic we discuss
and we talk about lead with warmth,
follow with competence.
>> That's exactly it. Yep.
>> And and that can make a big difference.
Thank you for sharing.
Uh who's a communicator that you admire
and why?
>> The person who popped into my mind and
it's possible that it's cuz I was just
listening to a podcast from him is
Michael Lewis.
>> Uh-huh. Yeah.
>> And I think Michael Lewis is amazing as
a communicator because he has this
stroke of genius that makes him seem not
like a genius.
And I think that's where a true genius
sits. So a really good communicator, and
I think this is true in academia as
well, is somebody who can take really
complicated topics like the financial
sector or, you know, Kahneman and
Tversky's research in the behavioral
sciences and make it so simple that it
feels like you understood it already.
Like not very hard. Okay? And Lewis
as as well as as almost anybody I can
think of is just a master at that. Both
in writing as well as in speaking. So,
he's just as good on his podcast as he
is with his books. The other thing that
Lewis does which is great as a
communicator is extremely good at asking
questions.
>> Yeah.
>> He's really good about not imposing what
he thinks on somebody else. But rather
letting the other person share their
wisdom
and pulling that out of them. He's a
good perspective getter. Really good
perspective getter. And so, he's that's
why he gets the nod from me today.
>> Not surprising that you would pick
somebody who asks good questions giving
given what you do in your research. And
the other notion that you started with I
call accessibility. How you make complex
ideas accessible to somebody.
And I like that you added so that they
feel like they already knew it. And that
And I I know exactly what you're talking
about. And And really effective
communicators do that. All right, Nick.
Final question. Question three. What are
the first three ingredients that go into
a successful communication recipe?
>> So, I think the first big one is to take
an interest. A lot of good communication
is about the mindset you take to it. In
a conversation this is particularly true
I think if you're communicating
conversation is you got to take an
interest in the other person in getting
to know them.
People spend a lot of time focusing on
specific words to use or specific
sentences or phrases. I think that will
get you potentially over the hump to
start something. But what makes for a
really good conversation is for you to
be flexible in the moment. If I take an
interest in getting to know you
the stuff to talk about is just going to
come up. I'm going to think about it
often if I start with that. So, I think
being in the right mindset, taking an
interest in in understand somebody,
getting to know them, making sure they
understand you I think is critical.
If you're not interested, you're not
going to you're not going to teach them.
You're not going to reach them.
Second one is warmth. We already talked
about this a little bit. Again, I think
this is one thing that people
underemphasize
um or because because we're agents.
We're we're and and this is suggested by
the research
that what we kind of think about when we
think about ourselves is our competency,
right? I'm going to stand up and I'm
going to give a speech, right? I'm going
to or I'm going to talk speak in class
or I'm going to have a conversation with
you or I'm going to write a gratitude
letter to you, right? What I'm worried
about, I'm not concerned about whether
I'm trustworthy or not. I take that for
granted with myself. What I'm worried
about is what the heck am I going to
say, right? That's what I'm really
focused on. But what other people focus
on when they see us is is this somebody
trustworthy. So, warmth is a is a big
one. I think that's the second. And then
the third one I think is is openness.
People who are willing to share things
about themselves, be open about about
themselves, that builds trust very
quickly. So, a good way to really have a
deep meaningful conversation with
somebody isn't just about asking them
meaningful questions. It's also about
being willing to be open and share
meaningful things about yourself, right?
The fact that I was uh not all that long
ago, you know, 20 years or so ago when I
started my career, was a terrified
introvert at least when it came to
standing up and speaking. Sharing that
story, I lost 20 lb before my first job
interview. I was so nervous. I didn't
sleep. I didn't eat for weeks. I was
terrified by this, right?
Being willing to be open and share those
meaningful stories allows other people
to open up with you, too. Um and that's
what makes a really good conversation
and communication.
>> Yeah, that reciprocity there is really
important in building trust. So, the
three I hear you talk about are mindset
which drives interest and the
flexibility needed to to engage.
>> To take an interest, yep.
>> Right. And then and then that warmth uh
rather than over-indexing on competency
and then finally being open and and and
divulge and share information. Uh, Nick,
this was fantastic. You were so helpful
in illuminating the good work that
you're doing and helping all of us to
feel better in our communication and the
challenge that you bring to us, which is
to take that step, initiate the
conversation,
be a little bit more social and you can
see the benefits. Thank you for your
time.
>> Thank you so much, Matt.
>> Thank you for joining us for another
episode of Think Fast, Talk Smart, the
podcast. To learn more about how to
leverage communication for deeper
relationships, listen to episode 133
with Charles Duhigg. This episode was
produced by Katherine Reed, Ryan Campos,
and me, Matt Abrahams. Our music is from
Floyd Wonder with special thanks to the
Podium podcast company. Please find us
on YouTube and wherever you get your
podcasts. Be sure to subscribe and rate
us. Also, follow us on LinkedIn, TikTok,
and Instagram.
And check out faster smarter.io for deep
dive videos, English language learning
content, and our newsletter. Please
consider joining our Think Fast, Talk
Smart learning community at faster
smarter.io/learning.
You'll find video lessons, learning
quests, discussion boards, my AI coach,
and book club opportunities. Again,
that's faster smarter.io/learning
to become part of our Think Fast, Talk
Smart learning community.